[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une liste qui dépasse les clivages
gauche droite une liste libre de toute
pression politique
une liste citoyenne qui représente
toutes les générations tous les milieux
sociaux tous les quartiers de notre
ville c'est une liste qui a pour seule
ambition l'intérêt général de notre
ville et de tous ses habitants
et c'est surtout une liste où l'intérêt
l'ambition personnelle n'a pas sa place
[Applaudissements]
là pandémique nous traversons
aujourd'hui nous a montré l'importance
de prendre soin les uns des autres et de
vivre ensemble et justement ça montre
tous les sens d'un nos points phares de
notre programme qui est la citoyenneté
et le vivre ensemble la citoyenneté
ce sera par exemple la démocratie
participative réapprendre à vivre les
uns avec les autres et non pas les uns à
côté des autres
ce sera aussi la mise en place d'un
conseil un quart générationnel ce seront
des des moments festifs des moments de
convivialité et nous nous seront
favorables à toute proposition
d'habitants de claix siens que les
siennes allant dans ce sens du vivre
ensemble
[Applaudissements]
j'en aurai 2 pourquoi deux parce que
encore une fois l'enseignement de la
crise sanitaire que nous traversons a
confirmé l'importance de la mise en
place d'un plan communal de sauvegarde
plan communal de sauvegarde qui permet
justement des réponses faits établis
réfléchi à de futures crises mais
également je pense que c'est elle
souhaite beaucoup de clés siens la
révision du pnud afin d y intégrer la
sauvegarde de notre patrimoine naturel
et bâti qui sont l'identité de notre
ville
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]